[Music]
let's go out to
columbus ohio and talk to arlington
what's up arlington
hey how much dude how are you good hey
what's your nickname what do people call
you
uh they call me harley
arlington dude i like that very cool
okay my parents nailed it yeah
all right so what's up man
hey um yeah so i'm kind of looking for
some advice um
my wife
uh does a very good job of beating
herself up and i sometimes
don't know what to do
in the realm of maybe helping her get
out of her head and i don't know if i'm
doing something wrong
i think part of it comes down to i've
always been
pretty good at being like a
someone that people can come to when
life's getting rough um i just for some
reason i can't
get through that's the wrong way to work
it i can't
get to my wife the question i wrote down
is how can i help my wife um when she
gets stuck in her own head
does she have mental health diagnostics
um so
this past year
so she is a previously has been
hospitalized back when probably 20 years
ago um for anorexia um and
a lot of this stems from body image
issues and
more recently we've been in the
trying to get
hormones balanced came off of hormonal
birth control i'm trying to get hormones
balanced and that has just kind of
thrown a world of
unknown at her
that she
maybe just doesn't have the tools to
kind of handle on her own
say more about that are you saying that
as you're rebalancing hormones
like going through
hormonal rebalance is madness right the
way i've heard it described is you feel
insane because your head doesn't your
body's feelings don't match what's going
on in your head and it's just it's it's
out of it's it's madness right and
you're trying to then just show up at
work and be you know kind and
approachable and it's just insane right
it feels insane absolutely um
are y'all trying to get pregnant
um in the near future it's nothing that
like we're stressing out about right now
but it's definitely something down the
road where we we want some kids um what
made you want to what made her want to
go get her hormones checked and
rebalanced
um i honestly i think it was just uh she
was kind of done with being on birth
control
and kind of wanted to have
the feeling of being a woman who has
sustainable hormones that are produced
by her own body and things like things
like that okay
yeah and it's um i mean her and i are
very very different um like i'm always
quite optimistic about things and
a lot of hers is a negative uh self-talk
and um things like that and i
i i almost
after i made this call last week was
pretty tough um this week seems to be a
lot better and it kind of just yoyos
like that um what is what is pretty
tough i mean is she suicidal
no so i took a little leaf out of your
own book and just asked her straight up
because i was i was to the point where i
didn't know i was like hey man like
are you gonna kill yourself and she's
like no i just don't know what's going
on um
and so
not not that far but
just kind of
grasping at straws and not really
holding on to anything that's where
we're at okay
um
this situation is more concerning than a
traditional someone's just talking to
themselves badly
okay
so the way i look at these
generally is i'm looking at a trend line
yep and
this
there's a person here with a history of
disorder eating which tells me there's a
history of some sort of
anxiety ocd some sort of control which
may mean there's a history of some sort
of abuse or neglect am i onto something
there
um yeah i don't know if i've dug far
enough into the abuse or neglect but
everything else is spot on for sure okay
so
um
you deal it sounds like somebody who has
really been working on the symptoms
but has a body that is trying to keep
her alive
yeah a body that thinks that it's at war
with its environment which ultimately
becomes a war with itself
and whenever i've got a person who i
care about and i love and their bodies
at war with themselves eventually the
fighting gets so exhausting
and i don't want to die i don't want to
do drugs but i need this to stop
yes you see what i'm saying
and when i
it's like a someone on a skateboarder on
a sidewalk i'm looking at a trend and
just the few things you've mentioned to
me tom i don't like the direction of
this trend
okay
tell me i'm wrong
no i mean it's it's
i'd say pretty nail on the head um so
her and i met at work uh she
it was a pretty bad work environment for
her so she stepped away and now does
faking out of her house and it's kind of
become a little bit of isolation to
where
it's a ton of isolation super lonely
right yes and so she has done some stuff
recently and then like she is like
foot on the gas going like working for
it because she also realizes that like
she doesn't love the trajectory that
she's going okay um i'd say it's more of
like the rolling the ball up hill
and
it kind of coming back on top of her
time after time that's exactly right
situation that's exactly right um
so i want you to keep this in mind and
then i'll give you a strategy that i
would use if i was in your exact seat
okay okay
i want you to from this point forward i
want you to think of being with not
fixing
okay
that's been a shift that i've really
tried to do yes you can't fix her
what you can do is help create an
environment to where she can heal with
the work that she's gonna do
okay the creation of that environment
for most of us is a set of skills we
don't have
occasionally people have that and it's
amazing i didn't have it i had to go
learn it
okay
and so a great gift would be
i want to be the greatest husband
to you
and i want to love and support you
would you be willing to go to marriage
counseling with me so that i can learn
some new tools to love and support you
okay and this is you not trying to fix
her
this is you inviting her into
your skill development
okay okay this is about you
yes and it's not that you're so crazy i
don't even know what to do anymore it's
not that at all
it's how long have you all been married
uh about just over two years okay so
we're two years in
as we think about having a family as we
think about
it's gonna be a broad
this knucklehead on this podcast
is always telling us hey we get to paint
a picture of where we want to go and
then we get to live into this picture
would you be willing to go i'm just a
terrible painter would you be willing to
go with me and learn how to paint
see what i'm saying yeah and um she is
gonna take this my guess is as an
anxious person as a person who's
scanning her environment 24 7 for
threats she's gonna take this as my
husband's gonna leave me
or she's gonna take this as i'm causing
my husband to go crazy
and you're going to have to speak to her
in the way that you know her she's your
wife
in ways that she can hear you
that no no this is about me i want to go
i want to go learn some new stuff
okay
when it come you can draw boundaries in
a home
and
my wife did this for me so i don't this
isn't for everybody and i can see a way
where this might be shameful so you're
gonna have to know your wife and it may
be something you talk over with your
counselor
but my wife said i will no longer
tolerate anybody talking to my husband
in negative ugly ways and that starts
with you
and that's how she couched it it wasn't
hey you need to fix your negative
self-talk
it is i'm not going to allow somebody to
talk to my husband like this
okay right and so you can set up
boundaries and say i love you too much
to let anybody talk negatively about you
call you unattractive call you
overweight call you crazy call your
whatever
i'm asking you
to not talk to my wife that way
okay and it might be one of those things
that you call it out my wife can she's
going to look
very very very similar to kelly except
way less mean
and she'll she can look at me and i'll
know like oh yeah i just did that thing
right
um and so that can be a way to lean into
that but it's a again it's a it's you
owning the boundary it's not her fixing
a problem
yes yeah yeah see what i'm saying
um
are her is her family involved or are
they part of the problem
um
i'm gonna say a little bit of both uh i
totally
they usually is right
yeah no i mean they are the most loving
uh loving parents they are awesome um
but i think a lot of times
her mom has a lot of anxieties as well
and i can see that kind of not stirring
the pot but
not always being the most helpful but i
would also say that her mom a lot of
times is the most helpful um because she
knows how to talk to her sometimes a lot
better than i do
well or she knows how to push her
buttons a lot better than you do
in some ways yes as well yes um she
needs
there's gonna come a moment when that
relationship's gonna have to be
minimized in a dramatic fashion
okay
um that's probably best done by a
counselor
unless you find yourself between your
wife and her mother who's both the curse
and
has made herself the blessing too
yeah um and that's a hard place to find
yourself you may have to get there at
some point my hope would be that a
counselor could point out some of those
behaviors and which relationships are
feeding and nourishing her i'd also
recommend y'all start inviting people
over to your house
just go first and be weird about it and
be vulnerable about it and just say hey
we're gonna have three people over let's
just make a commitment to
twice a month let's have people over
even though we can't afford it they can
all bring we'll have cereal night
whatever who cares yeah um we'll do
whatever we'll get have game night we'll
do something but we need to inject
people back into our lives because yeah
that this working from home thing
um i get it i can imagine it being
wonderful and i can also it's destroying
people when it comes to loneliness
absolutely destroying people so
uh or if she wants to y'all want to look
at her going back to an office somewhere
else um but my guess is
she's gonna have to do the work to heal
trauma that's gonna allow her body to
stop
just
raining those alarms down on her 24 7
so that
she can sleep and finally be at peace
so that her hormone regulation and all
these other things that we're trying to
fix on the periphery here and hormone
regulation is actually on the periphery
that's i mean you get some hormones
lined up and you're talking about life
change right but sometimes getting their
space
um and that's both for men and women
it's just tough but
we need to get that body her body to
have peace right absolutely that's going
to start with relationships and sit down
and talk to somebody is she seeing a
counselor right now
she is yeah
uh how's that going
we bounced around to a couple
i don't know how
much of it is
um
it's her
it's her yeah
and my guess is every work environment's
always toxic
and you may be the one guy who's gotten
through is that fair
yeah
my guess is every relationship at some
point turns
to come after her is the way she feels
is that am i right
yeah
at some point she's gonna have to look
in the mirror and absorb she's the
common denominator in all of those messy
relationships
okay and that is both a scary and
daunting um
realization
yeah
ugh okay i hate that for y'all
am i i mean is there ever a time that
she's like this person and you're and
you think i mean come on
uh as far as like going
like full bore like i can't believe this
person did this thing
yes
yeah
okay or if you find yourself in fights
you're like yeah and you're kind of like
i mean it's not that big a deal
you i mean uh yeah yeah yeah okay so at
some point we're going to have to make
peace she's got to make peace with
maybe my body is reacting to people in
ways that is not consistent with reality
and i'm going to have to re-learn how to
have peace in my life so that i can
re-enter relationship with people so
that i could actually be well
right and that's when i tell you about
that trend line man i just don't like
the trajectory here because the this
trend spins the top spins faster and
faster and faster and it gets more
tangled up and more complicated to
unwind
right
from a uh so i work at a i work at a gym
um
and i mean that's where we met and so a
lot of the
i and again you may be able to speak
more into this um the body image stuff
seems to be quite heightened um
at the gym just because of the like
external looks that people are trying to
give themselves sure um
i'm
is that something that's worth like from
my end worth
trying to
move
myself
out of
uh quit your job
what's that like just quit your job
i mean in a responsible like
move on so we can both get out of that
absolutely environment absolutely okay
enviro i mean
ultimately those alarms are our body's
response to our environment
okay and when our our bodies are
detecting threats in an environment that
aren't there then we're then the the
alarm needs some tuning right
yeah um but if i keep throwing myself
back in a toxic environment that i know
is not good for any of us then yeah
okay
again i'm in that like like you said i
know i can't fix but i might be able to
support and so i'm in between that um
is me continuing down that line
kind of help
lead to the environment that becomes
toxic
um yeah i mean
here's a better way to to frame it um
my wife is equally a part of this job
because now people take pictures of us
at restaurants
okay and people send me direct messages
about my wife
right by the way if people do that i
just blocked you instantly i just i mean
um only my closest friends can make fun
of my wife right so i i
she's a part of this
and at any moment
if she said i'm out i cannot be a part
of this
then i would be out
and that's a choice i've made in that
super counter culture because the
culture the culture is like no you you
do you and if she can't hang then
i'm not doing that she's my priority
right correct and so there there's
like
i can't imagine being 80 and being like
oh
i'm so glad i remained a tick tock
sensation over that dumb marriage i had
for twitter that just seems insane all
right
yeah and so um
if you were put on earth to help people
with their physical fitness that's
that's a conversation i believe that
my role here is to help people be a
little better off than they were before
they met me
and i can do that at mcdonald's and i
can do that on a youtube show
and that's also why my boss interviewed
me for 18 months and my wife came on a
lot of those interviews too because it
was
i need you to have a full picture of
what you're taking on here
yeah right so there was that's part of
it but so it's less about i don't want
you to get in a tail-chasing
game where you're trying to figure out
what's the next thing you could do to
make this maybe help this because dude
then you're going to be in a mess right
but you can say
there's an overall toxicity to our home
um
because of the work i do because of the
schedule i keep because of i've got to
be on my phone 24 7 saying yes to
clients and somebody canceled i got to
find another client
because
um i had these dreams of making seven
figures as a personal trainer and i'm
making forty one thousand dollars a year
like all the those are the contributing
factors here right
um if my wife ever came to me and said
you're not allowed to ever help another
person ever again well that'd be a
different conversation but also she
would be my wife at this point because
that that would be madness right we
would have had that conversation a long
time ago
but she can tell me hey i need you to
quit running around in the middle of the
night um dealing with people who've
passed away because it's it's
impacting the way you treat the kids
that's very fair that in fact that's her
that's her role in my life and vice
versa and so yeah i mean if you can
change the context i'm all for that
don't do it thinking that that's going
to be the hail mary pass that's going to
heal your wife because it won't be but
it might take some of the toxicity out
of the environment and for you to even
be asking that question says a you're
really attuned caring husband and b
makes me think you want out anyway right
so
good for you good for you but um
she needs to go see a counselor or a
psychologist and you all need to stick
with that for a season
um we're gonna commit to seven sessions
we're gonna commit to ten sessions with
this one person
and we're going to ride out the
relationship and so when it gets
uncomfortable we're gonna go through the
discomfort and stay in the relationship
we're not gonna run from it because we
run from every uncomfortable
relationship
and by the way arleigh don't be
surprised at some point
this i'm run i'm disconnecting from this
relationship gets aimed at you
okay and you're gonna have to decide i'm
gonna ride the rough rough waters
um
she needs to go see somebody and be
consistent and i would love to see you
um say hey i want to learn something new
and i want you to come with me it's
awesome she's lucky to have you harley